this menorah is a real Texas menorah
most people who know much about menorahs
don't know anything about armadillos and
the people who do know about armadillos
certainly don't know anything about
menorah it's very usual to find people
like myself had know about menorah and
armadillo amiko Tortorella
I'm an actor an activist and a firm
believer that our differences actually
make us stronger I'm on a journey with
IKEA to meet real people and discover
the diverse and spectacular ways they
celebrate the holidays maybe you
celebrate the holidays with traditional
food and decorations or maybe you
celebrate them with your band mates and
a guitar in hand like country music
legend Kinky Friedman hi this was Kinky
Friedman I write songs
what would you say your greatest
achievement has been well playing the
Grand Ole Opry oh yeah what year was
that
73 mmm and that's where I was introduced
as the first full-blooded you to ever
appear on the Grand Ole Opry stage years
later I discovered that Nelson Mandela
had smuggled tape cassettes in his
prison cell in Robben Island and one of
them was sold American my record I never
dreamed that Nelson Mandela would be
listening
Kinki celebrates the holidays in a very
non-traditional way he gets his chosen
family together his band mates people in
his community its friends they get
together and they play music pinkies
Jewishness made him stand out gave him
this real powerful angle to write from
he uses this common bond of music to
spread tradition an important thing
about being Jewish is that you are
definitely on the outside looking in but
that's where the best material comes
from if you're an author of any kind or
a songwriter or just a human being
that's where you more clearly see what
life is all about where the only
heart is a broken and the only true love
and unspoken - whoa
[Music]
in years past Kinki has embarked on
Chanukah tours this year we had a small
concert with some locals at the ranch
that I used to know now it's me and a
three-legged dog
freedom as unique as kinky is his
interpretation of Hanukkah is as pure as
gold maybe he doesn't celebrate it the
way you see on TV maybe those are the
things that make his tradition so
special
quit in either
[Music]
[Applause]